2021年6月の29日
夕方くらいですかね本日をもちまして私
肇社長
チャンネル登録者数90021万人
親分であるし課金さに
抜かれました
うーん
抜かれましたーーー
あああああとはならないですねやー
そうですね抜かれました迎えましたもう抜かれたなって感じです
どういう心境なんだろうなぁすいませんよねほんと何も考えずにそれで抜かれてかもう
今日別な撮影してて撮影に帰ってきてまぁ速攻食べて動画撮ってるんですけど
なんか
悔しいですよもちろん来やすいです悔しいですね僕もともとチャンネル登録さっ
ヒカキンさん抜くために頑張ってきてたんでその目標を超え今改めてまたヌいてヌいて
ヌカレーっての感じなんですけど
悔しいというかなんか複雑ななんかいろんな感情が混じっている状態ですね
ちょっとヒカキンさんに電話してみよでるから俺ちゃんと覚えてるんだよな俺がね
ヒカキンさんのチャンネル登録者数といった時に課金さんが twitter でね
ベジータが送ってきたの俺覚えているちゃんといらっしゃいます
[音楽]
出なかったちょっとか彼らがそうなちょっともうちょっと方と国家ちょっと避け撮って
んだけどねでらんねー
この後編集あるんですけどまあとテツ南カイチじゃないじゃないですねまあね日本3位
ぐらいっぽいんですけどもなんかまたヒカキンさんに抜かれるのはちょっとまたばけが
違うんで
1と2はそれなんか姉マルチクリエイターユーチューバー
みたいな感じじゃないんで本当にペ
っと争いで迎えたなという感じで乾杯
お疲れ様です
まあ5年ぐらい経ちましたねはじめ殺王がトップだって言われて5年ぐらいたってあの
正直に話すねそうぜひ話すんですけどめっちゃくちゃプレッシャーだったんですよ
はっきり言っメッツプレッシャーだった星あの
前に人はいないんですよキッズダンサーと思いますけどまた戦う土俵が違うからなんか
戦っている感じがしなくて
なんか目指す目標というか同じ畑で
追いかけるべき一見失っちゃってまあなんか
正直ヒカキンさんを前に抜いたときに
小継俺なんか完全燃焼をしちゃってたんですよ
もうやりきった感が掃除あったんでまあなんか追われる側の辛さというか
最近のたほら com .とか当該親も勢いすごいです4位はノイズバーがトップ
目指してきている中で一番最前線にいるのってすごい自宅版でもちろん言葉にも出せ
ないし表情でもてないと思うんですけど出てなかったと思うんですけどこ
このどこかでやっぱりそのヒットに追われるヒカキンさんが迫って来るっていうやっぱ
抜かれたくてないんですよ結局
結局抜かれたけどない辛さの追われるっていう苦しさをねあの子の守護年感じたずっと
感じておりましたぶっちゃけで話すとね pop って大変ですよ本当にきっちーんで
ほんと大変ですよ
3位なんですけどザクリエイター見た youtube の中だとイマイチだったので
常に比較対象にされるし
面白い動画じゃないとダメだとも思うし悪いことももちろん認めませそれもトップ関係
ないけど誰しもそうなんですけど
より一層気を使うといけないしトップになってからもうね色々塩蔵とかもしましたし
右往左往あって今あの
オワコンじゃないですからねチャンネル登録者さんは一応ちゃん増えてはいるんです
けどでも俺がどうこうというよりもヒカキンさんがすごいあの人にだったら俺は抜かれ
ますがそもそも
面かすごい寺墓地気になっちゃうんですけどそもそもねやっぱりあの課題があっ
俺の上に立ってて欲しいという気持ちは
ああ
あります手間いけそう緊張する直接話そうひきつっパック
あもしません
始めてほしいをつけたのです s day 3スキャン検査
あなたがナンバーワンねー
ありがとうございます使われるそうですよ今日の夕方くらいに帰化議員さんに
チャンネル登録させから抜かれてしまいました
ああそういったロス大根ちょっとー
つかよって来ていただいててバーでもあれだね1000万がお互い次回からそうですね
頑張りたいねー
東行きので頑張りましょうよ分
英智海洋0で900万からの1000万所を一度にね
真面目に頑張る車頑張りましょう
いやずっと本はを呼ぶの背中を見てまた頑張ってください
ほど潜ったら俺ねえじゃあ方こそない半端なんけど悔しい悔しいですけどなんか親分と
はどっちかというと一緒に頑張っていきたいなと思っているので一緒に大蛇土田て
もらえたらいいよねーとまあそれまでお互い体に気を付けて頑張りましょう
今後ともまあ
ブーブーリスペクトてょロスはい
ということで頑張りましょうあると荒れてますおめでとうございます
セキュリティいる
バイバーイっ
おやすみなさないんですけどって
好きああうわあもう1本とにさあ動画ず伝わらないけどの裏でも本当にしたわよどん
だけ細いかとねちょっと親分と比べてしまうと僕は人間としてはまだまだかなっていう
部分は多いですけど自分でも負けてない部分としては本当に
動画が大好きヒカキンさんも好きだなあ日か今朝も好き実は
開けてる負けないとかの話じゃないんですけど動画が好きって気持ちは若者誰にも負け
ないと思ってるんで
今後とも
g の山を降りまして方がとても軽くなったのでは伸び伸びと今後は web の背中
を追いかけさせていただきます
庄司頃に一対は俺に合ってない俺のからじゃない追いかけるがーじゃない俺はもっと何
か言いかけてたいんでなんかホント狂気に目が覚めたといいますか
ちょっとまた目標ができましたね
熱い差を追いかけるという
あの人にだったら俺はなカレー
漆抜かれるべきそしてそのヒカキンさんは俺はまた追いかけるべきかなと思いました
うんちょっと今の心が鬼没スティはも本当に悔しいのとホッとしたっていうのと
また目標ができた勝って優勝席種5年前に俺燃え尽きてるんで
目標者があって色々とちょっと方だしたから
変わりそうですねようやく来ましたか-23
待ってました今後とも始めたぞよろしくお願いします
いません
けどは8分だったらいいちょっとあの1入ってプレーした抜けなんでちょっとまた
ハトメちゃら動画だすかもしれないけどね炎上させないで
もう一じゃないんだから責任感が襲うこと言われてもあのが乱れや一定的なその良識の
範囲なには頑張りますけどもっとあの
気楽にやらせて欲しいという気持ちはあるなんかすごいツイッタとかイースターの dm
とかでサーム金田中でた頑張れが
まるって言われるけどあの頑張ってどうにかな世界じゃないんですよ
クリエイターさんから気付いてると思いますけどがんばりも大事ですけどどっちかと
いうと楽しむとか自分が面白いとか素敵だと思う逃すことが大事だと思って始め社長
応援してくださる方には
俺も自分が楽しんでれば伸びるということはもうはっきりと数字が証明してくれてるん
で是非楽しんでー
海を目指したいと思います
[音楽]
voodoo
w
[音楽]